hi caesar hi guys how are you good
morning i have a surprise for your final
challenge
for the past month caesar has worked
closely with the calderons a family of
first responders with a red zone pitbull
named bella
after two attacks
the family may need to surrender bella
if they can't control her excitement
the last time i came here to work with
bella it was because she escaped out of
the front door to attack another dog i
need to know that we work through her
dog aggression
to put bella and jennifer to a final
test i'm going to have my son andre walk
a dog by their front door to see if
jennifer can keep bella in a calm
surrender state all right andre
i could see bella switching into attack
mode her body was getting tense her eyes
were getting fixated on the husky i just
need to do a proper correction to remind
jennifer how to keep bella calm
there you go
this is more calm surrender yeah
andre
you do it again
there you go that's the one so whatever
you did and whatever that intent that's
the intensity so you don't have to like
do it three times this is huge for her
she normally would have been yeah and
this is her true nature her
happy-go-lucky self that we all love
there you go
this is more calm surrender
vel and jennifer are doing great so far
so now i'm going to push their limits a
little and see how they react when
confronted with another dog andre yes
sir i have my son andre moving slowly
with the other dog to prevent bella from
feeling threatened i want to see how
bella chooses to react to a dog entering
her space calmly
so now we have to come surrender can you
see it
so that's why it's so important to
assess and evaluate how they feel not
what they did what they're doing right
now yeah right
yawning is good
a yawn equals relaxation it means calm
surrender vela has a troubled past but
you can see that that's not going to
define her future i do walk her i
usually put the weighted vest and her
goggles on just to help decrease i want
to see the whole thing i'm so proud of
all the work jennifer has put in she's
even using tools like way the best to
burn energy she looks oh they have pink
yeah oh my lord
i love it even more
when we put it on her she's much calmer
and goggles that work like blinders on a
horse together it's all about
controlling bella's excitement
ready
showing great success remaining calm
when faced with old triggers
caesar takes this once red zone pit bull
for a final neighborhood walk
when i first met jennifer she was
getting dragged down the streets by a
dog ready to fight anyone that stepped
in their path these dogs never got
exercised because it wasn't safe to walk
them so now i want to see how jennifer
handles a walk with all the tools and
knowledge she's gained throughout vales
rehabilitation don't forget distance
also look come this way there you go
distance is respect we were so concerned
that we would have to find bella a new
place to live and then working with
caesar learning all the tools and see
that she's happy-go-lucky and she's not
really responding as much to other dogs
it made me feel better and giving her a
second chance it's all thanks to caesar
much better right yeah this was great
this is it
normally she would have already been
barking right now she's she's actually
in a super happy-go-lucky feeling right
now so enjoy this part just like this is
good yeah exactly so let's focus on
those little moments but it's just
awesome seeing the progress has actually
fueled my fire to keep on progressing
with all the dogs caesar i just want to
thank you and there's nothing i could
say that would uh repay what you've done
for our family it was awesome to be a
first responder for once
that's pretty cool you definitely were
appreciate you very much did amazing
[Music]
you